and what are you doing detective what
are you doing talking to my client
without me present you sneaky
Pete what did the academy hire you right
out of the womb you guys get younger
every
what'd you say to Babyface huh how did
you say anything stupid by anything
stupid I mean anything at all I look at
you mouth open vocal cords of Twitter
and we'll talk about it later right now
you out 10 minutes ago go on there are
laws detective have your kindergarten
teacher read them to you right go grab a
juice box have a nap go on
foreign
who do we have
Brandon Mayhew Brandon Mayhew
all right
Brandon Mayhew
ah here we go public masturbation what I
don't get it what's the kick why don't
you do it at home like the rest of us
with a big flat screen TV 50 channels of
pay-per-view in a Starbucks that's nice
that ain't me man I
I was the guy who was selling meth
allegedly
hey all right I got you math rights I'll
say that was a little transpositional
error nothing little white out can't
take care of
yeah and uh felony quantity
which is apparently yeah just barely the
cops around here are like butchers
always get their thumbs on the scales
you know but good luck arguing that in
court
let me get down to brass tacks I'm gonna
get you a second phone call okay you're
gonna call your mommy or your daddy or
your Parish priest or your boy scout
leader and they're going to deliver me a
check for four thousand six hundred and
fifty dollars I'm gonna write that down
on the back of my business card okay
four six five zero okay and I need that
cashiers check or a money order doesn't
matter
actually uh I want it in a money order
and uh make it out to Ice Station Zebra
Associates that's my loan out it's a
totally legit it's done just for tax
purposes and after that we can discuss
Visa or Mastercard but definitely not
American Express so don't even ask all
right any questions
uh you're gonna give me off right
what do I look like your high school
girlfriend five fingers no waiting
that's a joke Brandon lighten up
son
I promise you this
I will give you the best criminal
defense
that money can buy
you're going to give Badger Mayhew the
best legal representation ever
but no deals with the DEA
all right Badger will not identify
anyone to anybody if he does
you're dead
why don't you just kill badger
I mean follow me guys with mosquitoes
buzzing around you it bites you on the
ass you don't go gun it for the
mosquitoes attorney you could go grab a
fly swatter so to speak
I mean all due respectful do I have to
spell this out for you
we're not killing Badger yo then you got
real problems okay because the DEA is
gonna come down on your boy like a
proverbial ton of bricks I mean I I
don't think I'm going out on a limb here
but hey he's not gonna like prison he's
gonna sing like Celine Dion regardless
of what you do to me
Mr Mayhew
recognize your cough take that mask off
you don't get some air one
take it easy breathe in breathe out all
right I'm gonna stand up all right
because I got bad knees
that's better
okay now now I'm listening to three of
us I'm gonna work this out yeah how
first things first you're gonna put a
dollar in my pocket both of these
you want attorney client privilege don't
you so that everything you say is
strictly between us
I mean it put a dollar in my pocket come
on make it official
come on do it
that's it come on
just a dollar what
all right now you ski bomb come on give
it the dollar
come on be smart
I got some five I'll take a five come on
already come on
be cool
okay you're now both officially
represented by Saul Goodman and
Associates your secrets are safe with me
under threat of disbarment all right
take the ski mask off I feel like I'm
talking to the Weather Underground here
do it
okay so if a prison shanky is completely
off the table
and we're sure of that
no sinking
right right
and the way I see it is
somebody's going to prison
it's just a matter of who hello
good afternoon nice to meet you Saul
Goodman nice to meet you you're not that
lawyer on late night television Are You
Better Call Saul
I get it all the time
we're here to discuss the sale of the
property at 9809 Margot I get it flat
fee clients am I right well folks
today's your lucky day I represent a
client who shall remain nameless however
for our purposes you might just as well
visualize a large bag of money this
individual wants to buy your house today
for cash cash
I know in this economy
the money is already burning a hole in
my clients like you can ask Mr Gardner
from all the pertinent financials it's
the only reason we're sitting here
fair enough yeah get a few papers signed
and notarized we can take care of this
right now in fact I could wire you your
money this very afternoon it's just one
little hair in the soup
the
price
we feel 8.75 is very fair no but I
suppose there's always a little uh
wiggle room
well why don't you wiggle us on down to
400 and you got yourselves a deal
four hundred thousand what is that a
joke no that's
that's less than half price
we put almost that much into the
renovations alone why don't we just cut
the clown act and you tell us what
you're willing to come up to four
hundred thousand that's
well this is a waste of time did you
possibly imagine that we would entertain
this come on I don't know I just thought
some allowance was in order once I heard
about the meth lab
one that used to be in the basement I
looked over your signed disclosure
statements and I don't see any mention
of a meth lab no no oh you got your
termite inspection that's good but no
meth lab now some would call that fraud
in service of concealing a felony I
myself am more open-minded but it is
tricky and don't get me wrong I applaud
your cojones I mean
good try I'm sneaking up meth
contaminated property past the buyer I
mean
could have been a good deal for you too
bad now I could
file a suit and encumber this property
indefinitely Or could start some
criminal proceedings I don't think any
of us want that now do we
about a counselor
do you concur
hello welcome
what a pleasure it is to have you
I'm just going to call you Skyler if
that's okay it's a lovely name reminds
me of a big beautiful sky Walt never
told me how lucky he was prior to recent
Unfortunate Events clearly his taste in
women is the same as his taste in
lawyers only the very best
with just the right amount of dirty
that's a joke
it's funny because you were so clearly
very classy here please sit down
so all tells me that you have uh some
concerns I can alleviate uh yes I do I
have
concerns
um if we're going to go down this road
and
clearly we are for the sake of my
brother-in-law I've heard about him
he's an American Hero
at any rate I need some assurances that
we're going to go about this in a manner
that is extremely safe and cautious fair
enough
walk you through the process
first step is something we like to call
money laundering all right take your
money uh represented by saying these
jelly beans
so I actually I know what money
laundering is uh-huh well
yeah
and uh as with most things the devil is
in the details so to begin with what are
we saying is the source of this money
that's simple uh Walter actually came up
with a great story about gambling
winnings it was Blackjack writes some
card counting
um well actually that was Skyler's idea
foreign
you grow more gorgeous by the minute
well there you have it uh I'll generate
false currency transaction reports out
the Wazoo as well as the necessary w-2gs
and a couple Casino managers who will
jump at the chance to report false
losses it's a win-win for everyone yeah
but you can't sell that for very long
yeah yeah way ahead of you uh we
declared just enough so as not to arouse
suspicion then Walt's one-time winnings
become seed money for an investment
investment in what drum roll please wait
for it
laser tag
laser tag seven thousand square feet of
rollicking fun in the heart of Northern
Bernalillo County
laser tag
hey there's guns and glow lights and
kids wear the vests right no no I
actually I know what it is it's just
that in relation to Walt it's
I mean
it doesn't make any sense
makes more sense than YouTube being
together I'm still trying to figure out
how that happened do you even know Walt